start bench cut okay it's tough granny
Moss Chris Carter Justin Jefferson
goats man uh well I gotta start my boy
JJ okay okay
gonna get some heap of bench and Randy
and I love my boy CeCe but I guess he's
got to be cut there's no other choice
you're starting James all day okay
you can never cut
Chris Carter ever
Randy a good man
but you make a moss today
that's like asking me to tell you which
one of my kids is my favorite Randy Moss
because she's my favorite player of all
time you gotta start him and then you
gotta catch Jefferson and [ __ ] Chris
Carter I'm sorry Chris I'm starting
Randy I'll bench uh Chris Carter and
Jefferson's gone so I would have to
start Randy Moss dude number one in my
book Justin Jefferson is the youngest
stud like Randy Moss but he's not Randy
Moss's caliber yet I'm sorry Randy Moss
ah start Brandy bench Jefferson cut
Carter I'm sorry Chester Taylor yeah
[Music]
Randy Moss cut
DJ love you gotta go Randy A4 with the
hand up he's open oh her kisses nothing
but touchdowns but you had a gritty hey
I'm going to get us on the bed sorry
Chris Carter potatoes
Jefferson agree JJ has it made she he
could be better than all of them but
he's not yet Randy and all the rest